if you wake up and you feel like man I'm
giving giving giving and these four I've
been giving aren't returning well you're
in control of stopping your giving
people struggle with the concept of
giving without expectation even when
they say it and then when I say to
friends who are good at giving to a
point without expectation but then
there's across the line where they start
to subconsciously or consciously expect
I just remind them to not cross that
line so how do you recharge yourself by
not crossing the line or when I do cross
the line by being fully accountable that
I cross the line and so I can't be mad
at Johnny or Sally or Ricardo I cross
the line true giving true love true
kindness is genuinely not expecting in
return having expectations for something
in return is fine it's just a different
version of that that's giving with
expectation and I argue that a lot of
people fake give and are manipulating I
think there's so many people that
posture people love to say what they've
done on their terms that nobody asked
for and then cry about what they didn't
get in return